the only one who gets to decide if I'm
through is me you may not be done but
everyone's exhausted this is the scene
where Diana has made a number of
attempts at this swim from Cub to
Florida which is her lifelong dream
right you majorly offended Bartlett and
uh Nico's got to get back to work he's
got a new gig repairing AC's Nico says
it's the adventure of his lifetime she
is refusing to give up she enlisted her
best friend Bonnie to be her coach and
her partner and they have failed
numerous times because of all kinds of
obstacles and so at this point it's
rational to stop I mean Diana is 60-some
she she's not able to do it and she's
exhausted not only Bonnie but the entire
team you really don't get it do you what
this is like for
us we're broke the time the emotional
toll I mean it's been years Diana we
suck it up we're a team right wow your
superiority complex is really screwed up
where it takes place in the story is
this critical moment where she's she
needs Bonnie to to do it with her and
Bonnie's saying no everyone should have
a superiority complex everyone should
feel like the star of their own life
yeah exactly my life my life and and and
I got things that I want to do yeah like
what I don't
know I mean that that's the crazy part I
I don't I don't even know what do I want
you know what do I want to do but guess
what I get to decide not
you I just think that you need to make
peace with the possibility of my death
what what does that mean I would do it
for you if it made you happy oh would
you would you do that and and some of
the things that that she touches on that
Diana touches on her her father for
instance her father was a monster
Imagine knowing in your bones that you
could do something that only you could
do like fate enough with the Fate Diana
niad I know what your name means my
father he was an yes he was an
but he understood my destiny he
was manic he was a dreamer he ended up
being a lot of things that she didn't
even know as at the time when she was a
kid but he did Inspire her to do it this
isn't a bad you or or your destiny this
is about me okay for once this is about
me she's bumping up against this part of
herself where giving up is just
impossible and everyone around her is
exhausted you don't even think of me you
just you just want me to like tag along
with you like like no of course I think
about you I know what you're capable of
better than you do listen to yourself
that is so patronizing jod as Bonnie is
coming up into how she has just given so
much of her herself to Diana she has
given up her profession she's given up
so much of her personal life and just
dedicated herself to Diana for years and
she's feeling used look I know that the
world wants me to shut my mouth and sit
down and wait to die but I didn't think
you did
stop I can't I won't I will not accept
[Music]
defeat are you with
me
no we worked a lot on the script the
development of the dialogue touching on
the moments about her dad who is a
pivotal figure in her life and he was
very complicated he was abusive and he
was also a big dreamer he played a
critical role in her life but he was
also uh incredibly difficult for her to
deal with this scene really uh touches
on this very painful Paradox of the role
that her father played in her life I
spent a lot of time with Diana sorting
out as best I could her inner life I
love her I think she's an amazing person
and she's got a lot behind her eyes
that's what I saw when I met her she has
a very rich inner life uh I spent a lot
of time with her she was very trusting
of me I really appreciated that and I
really dedicated myself like we always
do as actors just to try to to get all
of that out on the screen at some point
and jod did the same thing with Bonnie
and the four of us also spent a lot of
time together jod and I spent a lot of
time studying the dynamic that goes on
between Diana and Bonnie and sometimes
it's very intense it's like a marriage
they're not married they dated years ago
they are soulmates and best best friends
uh and the the nuances of their
relationship were fascinating so we
really studied them as best we could and
as careful as we could to try to to
tease out this this really specific
Dynamic that they've got going together
it's one of the the great challenges of
the movie and one of the great pleasures
of the movie was to try to dramatize
this very rich nuanced relationship
between these two very strong and
complicated
women working with Jimmy and chai on
these kinds of more emotional scenes
versus the physical stuff and all the
swimming in the boat stuff was really a
joy they both had great uh suggestions
ideas Jimmy had always had a very
intuitive uh sense of emotional truth
and that's what we need as actors and
chai also had they they're different but
they they had each had their own very
strong commitment to each scene and to
each moment I also depended a lot on on
jod because I knew as my partner that
she would be there for me and she was
and I was there for her and a lot of
working on a scene like this is
obviously not acting but listening and
responding to what you see in the other
person's eyes that's the real Joy that's
really the essence of trying to get out
see like this is is listening responding
and trying to find something that
surprises you surprises yourself
surprises your
partner this is the moment in the story
Diana's been swimming for about 40 hours
Marathon swimmers take breaks every oh
hour and a half or so um no one's
allowed to touch them but they're
allowed to take in water and whatever
food they can get in at this point she's
been up for almost 40 hours come up at
this point the marathon swimmers are
hallucinating they're not in touch with
reality they begin to really space out
and Diana knows this and that's why
she's got Bonnie there with her because
she knows that at some point she's going
to just completely fall apart and that
the only way that she's going to be able
to keep going is with Bonnie there with
her you're never going to put that mask
on
again
goggles all right the other thing I see
when I see this scene is I see all the
other elements that kind of enhance it
including claudo Miranda's light the
cinematographer and the Prosthetics that
we've got going at that point we had a
whole series of Prosthetics that showed
the gradations of the breakdown of
Diana's face in the water Diana look at
me I need you to you look at me no look
at me it's over no I I did we drift I
can make it up no it's a very kind of
gentle quiet moment because what she's
seeing is the lights of Key West I I'm
not getting out Diana stop stop I could
over it up look over there you see that
out you see that the Horizon look at the
Horizon you see
it is it the sun no
that's not the sun babe those are the
lights of Q West Diana what I'm telling
you is it's not going to be another
night just one big push if you can
really bring it if you can really really
bring it then you're going to reach
Florida today but there's still a long
way to go right at least 12 more
hours babe you got to you need to dig
deep you can dig deep all right we
worked really hard on it we thought a
lot about how do we get to to this
moment get some of this into you you're
doing great you're doing great everyone
was exhausted so this is really the last
push of the last swim and everybody knew
that Beyond this they weren't going to
be able to keep going Bonnie at one
point completely quits and she just says
I can't do this anymore I can't work
with you anymore Diana Diana kept
failing it was costing them money it was
costing them their
livelihood
Diana got to stay in closer to the line
of the vot i l the script so much when I
read it the story was so moving to me
and so inspiring that I just knew
immediately I wanted to do it but then I
had to figure out well how am I going to
get get myself to that place where I
could be believable as this Marathon
swimmer when I was training I started uh
working with Raa Owen who is an Olympic
swimmer she was in the Sydney Olympics
and she she really helped me believe
that I could do it we worked for about a
year and that was a joy I mean I think a
great challenge is something that most
of us really kind of want in life and we
don't stop wanting that just because we
get older so for me it became a personal
challenge as well as a professional one
that I really enjoyed and thrived on I
still swim I love it it's it's it's it's
the best and uh and the chance to play
this swimmer kind of opened up this new
uh personal joy for me which is the joy
of being in the water and swimming all
the
time we had an underwater camera
beautiful underwater camera operator
named Pete zukini and he was in the
water with me most of the time and he
would be swimming and shooting with me
simultaneously you know was a physically
demanding and beautiful effort on
everybody's part and I'm so grateful to
Joe
um her sense of emotional truth and her
commitment to the project was 100% she
had a lot of the great ideas for the
movie including the idea that Bonnie
would actually jump in the water and try
to swim beside Diana which in real life
Bonnie never did but Jody's idea was to
make that happen because it would be
such a powerful Moment In The Narrative
I love
you I love you too come on one more
stroke babe I have to say I think it
works pretty great just one more you got
it that's it that's it power come on
poweres